Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday fucking Monday morning
podcast that I've just checking in on
you. How's that? Is that the worst?
Is that the worst you've ever
heard? Um, Dave kept no reference.
Uh, sorry. My voice is a
little fucking blown out. Uh,
it did a record for episode six of the
10 that we're doing for a season two and
I don't know what the fuck I did to it.
Um, who's getting know when you know,
when you lack talent,
what should try to do is you're trying
to be loud so you can shout down all the
silence. That's what you do. You
throw in a couple of f words,
a couple of fucking shit jokes. And next
thing you know, you kind of have an act,
you know, and you scrape the bottom of
the fucking barrel. That's what you do.
And when you scrape the bottom of
the barrel, next thing you know,
you have your party's nomination
for presidency of the United States.
You know what's great about this job
is I get to meet a bunch of different
people and overwhelmingly people
on both sides or just going,
I don't know who the fuck I'm going to
vote for. These are my, these are the,
these are the two which
is supposed to decide,
added a fucking blue between
these two fucking lunatics.
I don't get it. Well, I get it. What
are you going to do? See the vote more,
the same or you step off into the abyss?
A,
I swear to God,
if Trump didn't hate non whites
as much as he seems to, uh,
or at least was wasn't
so fucking out of touch,
I'd almost be excited just
to see what the, what,
just just being a lazy comedian.
Just how this guy would just be fucking
feeding it to you. You know what I mean?
I found Obama was kind of
boring. You know, Bush was fun.
Clinton was Jesus Christ. Clinton
was fucking great, you know,
watch,
come over here and suck my Dick.
I mean it was so easy to get
laughs on that guy. And then Bosch,
and he's got old after a while, we get
it. He's fucking stupid. But like Clinton,
every fucking week he was sticking
cigars and people's fucking twats,
you know, he's bombing people,
he's putting on weight.
He goes to Mcdonald's and he's got his
fucking thighs out. I mean, that guy,
how he was, he was, uh,
he was a comedy juggernaut because he
keep kept changing every time you thought,
you know, all right, it's this, this,
and this, and you've got this guy down.
He would add another layer,
Bush,
which just Kinda hinky and then
another fucking seven years.
It's like, we get it, we get it. He's
fucking stupid. And he's not stupid,
but he's a, I don't know. I'll
quote one of my relatives.
He's not the best speaker.
Um,
I don't even, I barely even watched a
bomb borrowers or there. Oh ha ha ha.
I was just felt like he was giving me a
fucking lecture. It's like, all right.
I never really found any whom I found
his wife Hilarious fucking going on Ellen
and shit and tweeting.
You know what I mean?
I can like some seventh grade on
Instagram. She was funny, but uh,
I don't know about him. Um, anyway,
so hopefully whatever one of the other
you're going to tell you right now,
the both of them,
either one of them,
Hillary or Trump is going to be plenty
of fucking material but then instantly be
hacky. So maybe that's
what it is. I don't know.
All I know is I got 'em I got
'em doing this Wednesday night.
The hockey is over.
You get so excited to see somebody
when the fucking cup and then,
then there's like the next day like,
oh fuck itself. Now what do I do?
Um, I'll tell you what you
do. You get into Formula One.
There's another racist Sunday.
The fucking,
I don't know where the hell it it's
going to be. Is this the European one?
I don't. I got them all on my
phone. There's a couple in July,
Dennis as like one in August,
two in September.
Then like fucking every
Sunday in October there's one,
then there's two more in November and
then that's it. It's pretty fucking easy.
They're only a couple hours. You get to
watch somebody go like 200 miles an hour.
You get through to look in the crowd,
see all the people that go to
the Bilderberg meetings, right?
And sacrifice people.
And then you see a couple of baskets.
This is how much money's in,
in,
in fucking Formula One is when you look
at like the a list movie stars and like
fucking Zillionaire, you know, athletes,
they have a look on their face.
Like they can't even believe that
they're there. They're like, wow, these,
these people have money. We
thought we had money. And then,
then we came here and then we realized
that we did, we, we, we, we have money,
but we don't have that kind
of money. You know, you know,
back a fucking yacht into France.
He's fucking people back a yard into
France and fucking watch a race and then
continue on. Where do they go? You know,
you ever seen those people on yachts?
Every once in a while you're like,
where the fuck where they
go? And do you say like, you,
you cruise underneath of fucking,
you got your own mountain.
It's incredible. Um, you ever
been on a boat just by yourself?
Whenever I'm on a boat by myself,
I always had the same thought.
There's no fucking way I wouldn't do
something illegal if I owned a boat.
There's no fucking way,
the level of freedom that you
fucking have this shit. You can,
you're on a boat going
out of the fucking ocean.
Yeah.
All bets are off. You get out into
international waters. I mean it's fucking,
whatever you say becomes your law.
Literally do whatever
the fuck you want to do.
You're telling me right now if
you had a fucking bolt, right?
You know boss was at Dec,
right? Fuck. Ah, you know,
just so, uh, whenever they
promoted a woman, right?
Cause they had a fucking check off a box.
They got you a more qualified,
you came in every day with your qualified
swinging Dick and junk and they had
enough of it and they told you to stand
down and then they promoted this lady,
right? You're telling me
if you got a boat, right?
I don't know how he got the boat. You
didn't get promoted, but whatever.
This is my fucking fantasy.
Trash, trash and fucking,
it's hypothetical lady, right? I know.
This is be considered misogynistic.
This is the woman I ran
into the first 90 times.
I tried to get something on the air.
I just feel it's like this.
That would be the end of my dream,
but they don't have any power.
Uh, it's a glass ceiling. Well,
I'm running into their shoes over here
is they're banging their head on the
ceiling. That was been my experience.
Anyway. Let's get back to the fantasy.
You're telling me if
you got a fucking boat,
you know you're not going to just,
I dunno,
just a kilo of cocaine
just for the fuck of it.
Just to have that cash laying around
your house, you know what I mean?
Get a keg or have some people over,
cook up some steaks. That's the
way you do it. When you, when you,
if you're fucking drug,
it's just every once in a while.
Is there a way to do that?
And the in the drug game was the kids say,
can you just every once in a while
deliver a Kalo said no one picks up on it.
Right.
You still drive your dented Prius,
like make Jesus my car needs to
fucking bath. Like you read about,
I literally walked out of a
fucking liquor store today.
It wasn't for me cause I'm on the wagon.
Buddy of mine got fucking married.
Um, I couldn't make it
cause I was on the road,
so I just got them some fucking
champaign, shit, whatever.
And I forgot to get a card
before on stand. I'm giving
it to him. I'll just say,
hey, and I've got a card. He goes,
I don't worry. You've got the booze.
That's what counts. Sorry,
what? He'd drink up. Ay,
Yay. Yay me. Look at my eyes.
Right. And when the same
boat. Oh yeah. So anyways, um,
I came walking out of the liquor store
and a, I looked at my car and I got,
this thing's a fucking piece of shit,
but it isn't just on the outside,
you know,
on the inside, everything's
been taken care of. Right. I've,
I've maintained that thing
meticulously on the outside.
It's a mess on the inside.
It's beautiful, you know,
it's like an ugly person just waiting
for somebody good looking to come along
and discovered that,
you know,
maybe they have something to add
to the conversation, you know? Um,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about,
so I'm just saying this is
the way this is. If you're in,
if you're selling drugs,
this is what you do it.
If he can just do it like the way Bush
went to the fucking Army National Guard,
whatever the fuck he did,
we just showed up every once in a while.
You know what I mean?
Played Ping Pong,
dress like a sergeant and then you
went home for like fucking six months.
That's the way you deal drugs.
Okay.
Alright. Yeah. Befriended drug deal and
you go, listen, this is all I want to do.
I got a boat. Okay. Every fucking
once in a while, you know,
every whatever be fucking 18
months you call me up. Right.
You got to key is something why
you taught on the fucking boat?
I'll have it on ice.
You're the coldest fucking cocaine in
the universe and I'll fucking deliver it
over here. Right. You break me off
like fucking 15 grant. All right.
Then you just take the cash.
She just got it.
You got 15 grand in cash and you
don't fucking buy yourself anything,
you know, go out and buy a fucking flash
you fucking car or any of that shit.
All you do,
you just have it in a jar or some shit
and every once in a while big games
coming up. You know UFC
event, you fucking order it.
Yeah.
That's what you spend it on. You fucking
blow it on your friends, you know?
Okay.
It's some fucking barbershop chairs
in your house. Just some stupid shit,
you know? Nothing that caused that. That's
how you blow your fucking cash, man.
You could keep shit on the inside.
Right.
You don't drive around some flashy car
with the fucking elevator shoes whenever,
whenever, whenever the kids do today
I, I don't, I don't pretend to though.
That's what I would do,
you know?
Okay.
Then every once in a while, and I don't
know how to get into your bank account,
why would he do then if you've got to pay
for the UFC event and who gives a fuck,
you pay for it out of your ready a clean
money, you know, and then all the booze,
money and all the other bullshit you
just take out of the jar. There you go.
Be hilarious when you finally get caught.
You know,
he'd just go to trial and just like,
look, I just, every once in a while I,
it was like every 18 months, it's
not even a felony a year, your honor.
And you know, I just, I,
I didn't buy anything.
I don't even watches the
shit. I just, you know, I,
I got the NFL package
and I had my friends,
oh everybody had their
own leather chair ever.
You ever watch shows the Elvis
documentaries? Well, you know,
everyone's going to go horseback
riding and it wasn't enough.
He bought everybody a horse
and he got him a saddle,
then a little pickup truck
to put the saddle on.
I did that and the judge be like, oh,
is that what you did? That's great.
Well maybe you uh, can take that
given nature and go to jail and uh,
start giving some hand jobs because
a c United States of America Buddy,
you know,
do you get a kilo of cocaine?
Right? And then you fucking,
okay,
take your boat all the way out
into international waters, right?
And then I meet you on another boat and
then I hand you the key, uh, cocaine.
And then you give me the
money in international
waters and what both captains
and what we say goes and
we say, uh, um, I say,
this is legal, all in favor. Or we go, hi.
I could they do anything. I mean, once,
okay.
It's the dude who comes back in with the
fucking key low. He's in trouble. You,
once you get back within the borders,
you know what I mean?
Can you sit there, I'm really fascinated
with boats now. Can you fucking,
I don't even do drugs.
This is just fascinating to me.
Can you sit in just just on the other
side of international waters with a kilo
of cocaine out in the open.
Just blow and stripes is to
coast guards looking at you.
Just waiting for you to float another
40 feet over and just be sitting there.
Gone on.
Now I am the captain of the ship and
international waters and I say this is
legal.
Okay.
Yeah, it probably can't do that. Right,
because you know what they could do is
they could just come over and just say
that you were,
you were in within the borders of the u
s who's going to fucking know it's their
word against yours.
You brought there on the ocean.
There's a lot of questions
I have about the ocean.
This is one of the reasons why I don't
have a boat aside from the fact it's just
a fucking money pit.
You know what I mean?
Can have a boat. You can have a friend
who has a boat. That's the way to do it,
right? It's, my brother always said,
you don't want a boat pill. You want,
you want a friend to have a boat.
That's the deal. That's what it is.
Then you show up, you know,
bring Google, tango, rain
tonic, you were fucking heroin.
Then you guide dogs the
fucking boat and that's it.
He's cleaning off the barnacles.
You know what I mean?
He has to explain what happened to the
stewardess. She was here a minute ago.
I don't know. We were drinking and
she must have fallen overboard.
Right then that follows you around
for rest of your fucking life.
Um, anyways, so what do you guys think?
I guess when you listened to,
since it's Thursday,
so game six in Cleveland
to night to night to night.
Um, oh my God. Can you imagine if
they force a fucking game seven
that would be something else.
You know what I mean? Who knows?
Then you go out to fucking it lists.
I'm going to give some Cleveland
Cavalier fans some advice here. Okay.
God. Well and the force
of game seven. Okay.
Cause we're all trying to avoid
the dog days of fucking baseball.
You know what I mean?
Nobody wants to watch that shit.
The baseball players don't want
to play the games. They don't.
The only reason why they
play is cause if they didn't,
they wouldn't make as much money.
But nobody wants to fucking play baseball
from mid June to fucking like the
second week of September.
Any ballplayer,
if they could fast forward to all of
those fucking games and just get to the
exciting part. You know who's gonna win
the division? There's nothing better.
Then when it finally fucking matters after
fucking 263 regular season, whatever,
they play 182 games, whatever
the hell it is, 180 games.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know everybody in Chicago
getting all excited about the cubs,
you know what I mean?
Already rubbing one out.
They're going to bust a nut and
fucking the beginning of July.
You got to pace yourself.
If you're not watched any pornos relax,
cub, feds, put your
shirts back on. All right?
How many fucking times if you fell for
this, not saying I'm rooting against you,
but you know, slow your
roll here. Cubs fans,
the exp level excitement they get when
you watch them every fucking year.
It's literally like watching somebody's
fallen in love with a stripper, you know?
And you just sit in there like,
what are you doing? You know,
you fuck them. You don't fall
in love with them right now.
I'm kidding. The part of being a
sports fan, it's the fucking misery.
And you've got to believe
that's what you gotta do.
Take the kick to the seeds every fucking
year and then maybe one time they
actually win it. Then you talk about
that for the rest of your life. Oh,
what a year. They still live
in newspaper. A framed it.
Um, and then your wife throws
it out. Nah, maybe she doesn't.
Maybe she's cool. Right. Maybe
she wants us to sports too,
but then she'd probably fat,
you know,
looks like you got to start putting on
each other's genes in the morning and
just these minor, yeah. Fuck
that. They felt weird. Yeah.
Don't use and then not use of the cameltoe
fit here. I guess. These are yours.
Um, this has gotta be the most fucking
bizarre podcast I've ever done. Um,
it's cause I'm fucking exhausted
mentally from doing this shit.
Uh, I got halfway through this podcast,
I'm not drinking. And I was watching the,
uh, Jacopo story of Pistorious Sally
says named the fucking Bass player.
They're watching this documentary on him.
I read the book on this guy too.
And like the beginning is all great.
It's just once he starts
going off the rails, you know,
so I kind of paused it
right at the right part.
If you're watching the documentary
for the first hour and eight minutes,
but actually probably about
the hour and three minutes.
And then it starts to be like,
oh,
and then he did this and then did that
and then this fucking gap in this.
Then it's a shit show. Um, so anyways,
uh, to fuck are they talking about what
I'm talking about boats now I was talking
about the Cavaliers now is he had some
advice to Cleveland Cavalier fence. Okay.
God willing. You guys forced the
game. Six. Okay. Enough for you,
not for your city after the offense
for me. Okay. Cause they want another,
I want to more fucking games tomorrow
night and I want another one. Okay.
Before I slip into,
um,
the sporting a bis,
you know,
and I don't give a fuck that you only
have to wait another six weeks before,
you know, preseason football
starts. I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck about the draft.
I don't give a fuck about preseason.
I don't give a fuck about analysis.
I don't give a shit that the projections
and don't give a fuck about any of it.
Just let me know when it counts.
I am so fucking sick of watching people
standing up on a fuck in front of a God
damn screen trying to explain to me what
the fuck I just saw what happened and
why it happened. I don't
give a shit. I get it.
You played the game and you
understand it on a level beyond,
you know, just, I dunno,
just fucking show who one Taco over the
highlights and end the fucking thing.
You're going to sit around and
have God damned debates. Yeah.
What do you think was
happening in the transit? Well,
I think the problem with everybody knows,
I don't know.
I don't know shit about basketball,
but I can tell you right now,
if you fucking the Cavaliers
as a fucking comedian,
I know what they're doing wrong.
At least I think I do.
I would think if you up by eight points
against a team that can shoot the
fucking lights out and you'd want to
throw the ball around a little bit when it
was in your possession rather than
whoever gets the ball and crosses.
Fucking mid court just says,
I'm shooting it right.
It doesn't even pass the ball and you
take like two seconds off the clock.
It's probably not what you want to
do. Right. See that? I'm a comedian.
I can figure that out. Do I need
four people in fucking, well,
three people in suits and he got
to get a lady in there, right?
She's got a fucking,
she's got to run her. Yap.
She's got to put her fucking
2 cents in, right? You're the,
one of the worst fucking things ever is,
is to be a beautiful woman, you know,
and you're with a really successful guy.
You know,
and you just go around a
parties and then you're just,
you just stand next to the guy going,
is he going to introduce me as
you're going to introduce me?
You get one tie there. Hi.
Then he just stand there.
The other night I did a
Gig and there was this,
there was a scene afterwards and
there was all these fucking, you know,
rich people with their beautiful
wives and I just, I dunno,
I just started watching the
wives after awhile. I don't know.
Why don't they peel off
and talk to each other?
It's sort of a weird thing where
they just got to stand there smiling.
You can see their face hurting, you know
their feet hurt from the fucking pumps.
It's fucking brutal. If you're a
beautiful woman, what you should do,
you got to marry like a fucking six who
just can't believe that he's with you.
Cause he'll let you go out and wear
some fucking flatties some moccasins.
He doesn't.
You don't have to jack it up in the air
and stand there smiling next to him.
Like one of those fucking
psychos on the prices, right?
Waiting to fucking act like they're
amazed about a washer and a dryer.
Get a stand next to your fucking
guy's wearing a sport coat.
Try to cover up his fucking man tits
and you've got to sit there smiling like
you're happy. You know, putting your
fucking makeup on like some clown.
That's about everybody shut out of a
fucking cannon. You don't need that shit.
What are you doing?
They got to start. Well,
I'll tell you these fucking good
looking women that marry these really
successful guys and then just stand
next to him smiling, you know,
for the whole fucking evening,
like a stewardess at the end of a flight
except the fuck it takes four hours for
the,
for everybody to get off the plane
because by thank you for flying high.
You know who's fault that is?
It's their fault.
It's their God damn fault for getting
yourself into their fucking position.
Some point, the relationship, you got
to say, listen, hey mark, sit down.
We got to talk. Guess what? Fucking
Susie ain't putting on the shows tonight.
All right. Deal with it. Not
Standing next to you. Smile.
You want to go to a fucking brunch
and stand next to me smiling with some
aftershave on for fucking four hours.
I didn't think it did. Shut up.
I'm not finished. At some point you got
to have that conversation. You know,
I'm not trying to be mean here.
This is supposed to be empowering.
I'm saying you have the power and an up
just fucking standing there smiling like
a God damn. I don't know
why. I don't know what it is.
You know?
I don't know. I'm talking about,
I don't even know if I saw that.
I watched an episode of House of
cards, you know, house of cards.
I last like three.
I lasted like three episodes and I
just got sick of him fucking turning me
talking to me. It's like, dude, will you
just live your life? Stop talking to me.
They are right there as a secretary
of state. He doesn't know.
Then I'm fucking as well. I
shut up. I get it. I get it.
Just stop talking.
What does this,
the wonder years for adults? Um, Oh God,
I'm in a grumpy fucking mood
and I love Kevin Spacey.
Why would I say these sinks?
Why would I say these things?
Because I'm mentally fucking exhausted
and I got another eight minutes where I
got to run my fucking Yap
running my yap on the
Thursday afternoon podcasts,
talking about issues.
Um,
what else?
I don't know there have anything else.
I still haven't watched peaky blinders
because I'm trying not to drink and
there's no way to to watch that
show and not want to fucking start.
Just pounding.
Maybe I'll wait til like the 4th of July,
you know, I'll just watch.
That's what I'll do.
That's a good way to
spend the 4th of July.
I'll ignore my wife and just get blind
drunk watching a show that she can't
understand. You know, I put
on the subtitles, but she,
she didn't need is just not into it.
She just doesn't give a fuck.
We actually had this, we had this
argument the other night, right?
She goes to when we go to bed,
right.
She puts on the TV and she always has a
shows on and what's fucking hilarious to
me.
And she's always coming at me about my
temper and my yelling and flipping out,
screaming Atlanta and shit, or
yelling at the TV or my computer. Oh,
me and my computer, if you ever heard
the way I yell at my fucking computer,
you don't like that couple that just
needs to fucking break up. You know, we,
we got it in my neighborhood,
dude.
I'm telling you like fucking two houses
up that they've been very good lately.
You know?
But I'm telling you this like times,
like you're literally like
waiting to hear the gunshot.
It's like this just fucking insane
the way they scream at each other.
Okay.
It's the most unhealthy
fucking relationship.
Okay.
I've ever heard. And I gotta
be honest with man, you know,
sometimes I hear it and I just, I go out
on my porch and I just, I just listen.
You don't light up a cigar and just enjoy
it like it's a show not fuck with yet,
don't. Um, but anyways, so she's always
getting on me about my temper. And Shit.
You know what's fucking hilarious?
It was every fucking show she watches.
It's just a bunch of people
screaming and yelling at each other.
Those reality shows that it just wall
the wall clams. That's all. I mean,
you would think all these feminists out
there who is sitting there trash and men
up and down. All the bad stuff we do to
them. Admittedly. You know what I mean?
We make you stand next to us and
smile for an entire fucking party.
You know? Oh, I'm sorry. This
is my wife. Oh, I'm sorry.
This is the person that
committed my life to, I'm sorry.
Did I agnostic? Did I not even
acknowledge that you will fucking here?
They deal with that. I'll fucking
night. Right. All that bullshit.
I know we do that shit. But you would
think that these fucking feminists, right?
You'd think that they would,
they would have issues with these fucking
reality shows because the way they did
depict women is, I don't give
a fuck how many pairs of shoes,
how big the fucking houses, how much
Jules they got hanging off of them.
They still going to bitch that just
fucking bitch and each other out.
She was watching one of these
shows, right? And there was
just like, I don't know,
15 it seemed like there was 15 to
20 of them. So you know, there was,
it was probably just three,
but that's the amount of noise
of fucking woman can make. Right.
Three of them were sound like 15.
It's like their defense mechanism
because generally speaking,
they can't beat the shit out of men.
But if they just start complaining,
it just sounds like a platoon
in your back down. Right.
Instead of giving all three of them,
I'm one of those most slaps, you know,
when all three stooges would
get slapped at once. Um,
anyways, one of the episodes I
saw like, you know, like I said,
it sounded like 15 so realistically it was
probably like six of them, right? They,
they went to like Rome or some
shit. And I'm thinking, I finally,
they got these fucking women out
of this culdesac now they can,
now they can be excited to be in romp.
They go to fucking room.
They do the same goddamn think.
You know this bitch come up to me.
He started talking about, it's like
you're in Rome. You had dumb fuck.
Go look at something. Go eat some food.
I know it's just a show and whatever.
She watches that shit and I'm just
laying there. I hate the fucking show.
I'm trying to go to sleep and I just,
she just watches.
He's fucking shows where they
scream and yell at each other.
Now she's watching a fucking
show that's about a show.
That's a show that's like that.
It's a show about a one of those
reality shows like the bachelor.
You know what I mean? And I don't
know. I don't, I don't w w w what?
What? What the fuck do I
know? Right. 26 minutes.
Let's read a little bit of advertising
here. Why don't we do that? All right.
Type in the password.
You wouldn't want anybody to break into
your computer bill with all your secrets.
Oh my fucking slap fight
videos that I watch.
Why do I have a fucking
password? You know? Yeah.
I know this isn't going to work either.
At anytime.
I tried to do the past
with one fucking hand.
You know what kills me too is I wanted
to, yeah, of course. It didn't work.
I wanted a nice simple fucking password.
That was stupid content that keeps
telling me that it wasn't sick.
Sure enough,
you don't know.
All right, here we go. Loot crate.
What the hell is this shit? All right,
here we go. Loot crate. Everybody
ever been to comic con? No.
Wish you could take it home with you.
What an aqua man suit.
Oh Jesus. Bill, just read the copy.
Already. Have a little bit of,
it's sent to your home every
month with loot crate packs.
E three and comicon happen just
once a year. All this is some fun.
This is like some mega nerd
shit. All right, here we go.
Nerds perk up your ears. This is
like when they, after the super bowl,
when they sell like the programs and
the hats and all that and I'm like
[inaudible] don't know. Going to save it.
It's going to be worth something. Right?
Um, this is for the
nerds. Here we go. Okay.
So I've been definitely,
there's something called packs.
Evidently there's some called e three and
I know about comic con and they happen
just once a year each. That's like the
Grand Slam. Like you know when Golf,
you got the master's, she got the
British open, the US Open and the PGA.
Alright. Nerds have the packs,
the e three comic con, Eh,
uh, I dunno, some wonder
woman thing. I don't know.
Usually that shit doesn't happen in
a town near you. But with loot crate,
you experienced the fun every month.
Get exclusive products from top gaming
and entertainment franchise. You're,
your crate will arrive between the 20th
and 25th of each month. No commitment.
Your in control partner with top brands,
you get epic exclusives in Star Wars,
Nintendo,
marvel and more,
uh,
June's theme explores ways things
can go wrong with dystopia,
whatever that is.
Um,
it includes the classics of Robocop
Terminator Two Judgment Day and the Matrix
and new faves by,
I'd said faves,
bioshock infinite and fallout four.
I have no idea what any of this shit is.
You will get a figure cool collectibles.
And of course the DIS stop.
Just stop.
Horrific monthly t
what does it mean?
An action figure.
Go to loot crate.com/burn enter my code
bird deadline is the 19th at 9:00 PM to
subscribe and receive this month's crate.
When the cutoff happens, that's it.
Game over for less than $20 a month,
you get six to eight.
Him set includes licensed gear,
apparel, collectibles and unique.
One of a kind items.
This is an over $45 value
loot crate.com/burr and
enter my code a bur bur to
save $3 off any new subscriptions.
Um,
I did a Gig the other night where there
was like professional gamers there and
stuff. They make all this fucking money.
It's like the greatest thing ever.
You play video games for a living,
you know,
that's what this country has become.
It's become like you
turned your hobby like me,
I turned fucking around telling
jokes in a warehouse into a career.
Skype plays video games, you know
what I mean? You like Robin one out,
you get into porn.
God knows we don't manufacture anything.
And there's like two things
left in this country, uh,
growing weed and fucking,
uh,
starting a nonprofit.
You know what I mean?
Most of those are bullshit anyways,
right? We got to help people. Uh,
we got two pinkies. There's
a bunch of paint, you know,
parent to Pankey's affects most people.
A lot of people don't even talk about it,
you know, all they do is
just make it sound like it's,
it's a bad thing and then you all of
a sudden you just giving them money.
It was probably a bad example,
but you know what I mean?
Alright. Boll and branch,
everybody, Boll and branch as
you set out to improve yourself.
There is one simple thing you can do every
day to help you be your best in every
situation that's getting a good
night's sleep. A fucking, ma'am,
I can tell you four days sober, I forgot
what it's like to wake up and be like,
you know what? I want some
ass. Whoa. Ah, Boll and branch.
The rest you need wrapped up and they're
super comfortable luxury linens and
they do it right there. The first Benny
Company to be fair trade certified,
which means your sheets come
from the work. HAP workup,
happy hands and not from sweatshops and
beautiful package sheet packaging made
entirely from recycled and sustainable
materials. I wish more companies did this.
Um, all right. You can only get
their sheets in one plate place.
That's bowling branch.com where
you know you're paying for quality,
not department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets
for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go to bowl, that's B o l l and branch.com
and they'll let you try them out.
Risk free for 30 nights.
If you don't like them,
send them back rouse.
You have nothing to lose
and it gets even better.
Go to Boll and branch.com today for 20%
off your entire order sheets, towels,
blankets,
and do VA covers everything.
Plus free shipping and all their products
come beautifully packaged and their
signature boxes.
Go to ball and branch.com today for 20%
off your entire order and use the Promo
Code,
Burr Boll and branch.com Promo Code Paper
Boll and branch.com Promo Code Berm.
All right, there you go. What time
is it? How much time did I do?
Oh, 32 minutes. Oh, that was
fucking painless. Wonderful.
All right. Hey everybody.
I'm heading back these tomorrow.
Tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow.
I'm heading out and I got a,
I'm playing in New Jersey at
the New Jersey Pack Center,
Performance Arts Center,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Then up down in Atlantic city
on Saturday and then on Sunday,
uh, playing some goddamn place. All right.
All of the dates are available on
billboard.com. Guess what, everybody?
The, uh, the fucking Belfast
tickets are already on sale.
I'm doing two shows out there and I think
Dublin guests who the opener's going
to be a, when I say Joey, you say Rose's.
Joey. Yeah. Joe Rosa. Joe Doe.
Rosa.
Where there's something,
something and there's something
I was supposed to read.
Some all think comedy thing too. Where
the fuck is this? Say, where is it?
Hang on a second. Hang on a second.
I don't think it's come. Here we go.
Here we go. Weekly tweet. All
right. All right. You know what?
I'm not going to tweet about this.
I'll talk about it. Ah, Yannis Pappas,
one of the funniest
motherfuckers coming up.
All his characters and all of his
standup has a new debut album called,
let me be Yonis.
You get it instead of let me be honest.
Let me be honest. There's
Greek son of a bitch. Ah,
it's available today on all things.
Comedy records.
I got a tweet about this. I was supposed
to do this five fucking days ago.
What an asshole. I'm a tweet
about that right now. All right.
This has been the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday body podcast,
and I just checked in on you, uh, be a
little music here and then we'll play
a half hour is shit for a
podcast a long time ago.
Maybe a little bit of time ago, but, uh,
it's not gonna be this one. All right.
You can't have a great weekend.
Faster,
faster.
Hey,
what's
going on? It's a bill burr.
It's the Monday morning podcast.
Um, what is it? One 48,
one 49. There we go.
Just change west coast time and,
uh, I'm in a great fucking mood.
I'm not in the God Damn Airport,
you know?
Why don't we say, you know, like
you're gonna fucking talk back to me.
Um, no, I haven't. Great mood. I'm
actually in my apartment laying in my bed,
chilling the fuck out and uh,
I'm in a great mood. Even though I
had a, uh, I had a fucked up week.
Really? Bill, you had a fucked
up week. Why is that? Well,
I'm going to tell you, um,
I've been making jokes over
the last four months about me.
I'm driving a dented hybrid and
talking about how emasculating that is.
You know,
it's like already I'm driving a hybrid,
so I had to deal with everybody
going, oh, what do you effect?
You know what I mean?
Suggesting depth because I'm making the
air a little bit cleaner that for some
reason that on some level that means
I want to suck a dick, which is,
that's very childish,
yet effective yet effective.
It's very hard in a group situation,
one on one maybe can defend it,
but in a group situation when somebody
yells out, what are you affect?
What ends up happening is we'll even
guys who aren't in the social circle,
we'll start laughing and then it's
like, you know, you're fucked.
His people are laughing at the question
of what do you with saying like if you
suck Dick or whatever, you know, if you
were to start talking about, you know,
how,
uh,
you know how you're thinking about the
environment that actually digs the hole
deeper, you know, and the people
like, well maybe. Yeah, look at him.
He's talking about the environment.
Only people who are into the same
sex, uh, are into the environment.
They know. Funny actually about the
hybrid is a, when I bought it a year ago,
I got a ton of shit for it.
People make fun of the little tires
and everything else. You know,
but as gas prices have crept up,
I feel like for 60 to 40,
70 out here in the last Congolese,
um, all of a sudden people are now coming
up to me being like, oh, so what's,
uh, what's the deal with
those cars? You know?
And then they asked the usual dumb
questions like, can they go up the hill?
No, no, they can't.
Fortunately everywhere I want to go
involves driving on a perfectly level
surface if not a little bit downhill.
And then I have to say I take the long
way around and somehow I get back without
having to go back up the hill. I
just fucking drove down. I'm like,
what the it sell it God goddamn car
that doesn't go up the hill, you know,
asked me that question was my mother,
my mom asking me that
you were on a hybrid?
No, mom. I moved to Nebraska, moved
in Nebraska. That's what I did.
And it's funny,
there's no hills in Nebraska,
but there are tornadoes. Okay. Um,
okay, so this is what happened.
I've been driving around this fucking
dented car. Oh. If he knew that my page,
this is the Monday morning podcast and
I do one of these every single week,
you know,
people ask me questions,
people send me information and a whatever
and I babble about my life while I
hype upcoming gigs like the fact that
I'm going to be doing stand up on the
guys' choice awards this Sunday night,
June 22nd on spike TV guys,
choice awards.
I believe that comes on somewhere
between eight at night and four in the
morning. No, I think it's 10 o'clock
I don't know when the fuck it is.
If I was organized, I know that, but I
did six minutes of stand up that day.
I believe I'm going to whittle down to
three minutes and I had a great time and
there were a bunch of famous people there
and I was jumping up and down like a
girl scout inside, outside. I
was playing it cool. Like, Hey,
they're a person who I've always admired.
How are you? Yes. Nice to meet you too.
And inside of like God, I can't believe
I just shook their head and they said,
nice job. You're funny. It was a thrill.
I had a great fucking time. Um,
so I got that coming up. Oh.
Also this week I'm going to be
at the punchline in Atlanta.
One of my favorite clubs. See
little boy, a great mood on man.
What's the last week's podcast?
That was not a good mood.
That was me in an airport wanting to get
the fuck out of there. Oh, by the way,
for those weekly listeners of my podcast,
you know,
I was going from Raleigh trying to get
back to la because it's fucking Raleigh.
There's no direct flight.
I had to fly from Raleigh up to Cleveland
and then from Cleveland to fucking La.
Well, uh, my connecting
my Raleigh to Cleveland,
the flight was late because wind,
if you remember. And when I,
by the time I got to Cleveland,
my flight to La had already left.
So I had to spend five fucking hours and
the Goddamn Cleveland fucking airport
with, with, with, with, uh,
what was the big give me.
They give me a $15 voucher to spend
five hours in that fucking airport.
And I was a, I did my usual, I flipped
out a little bit. I was like 50.
And The lady's like, well, you know, I
actually hooked you up. They usually, uh,
I gave you the dinner voucher.
The lunchtime voucher is only eight.
You know,
that's one of those times you just
want to reach them across and just grab
someone by the throat even though they
didn't make the rule just to make you
feel better and be like,
bitch,
you don't give me fucking those to
fitness fucking airport for eight hours.
All right,
I want,
I want one fucking 30 bucks and I want
free Internet. That's what I want. Okay.
I don't want some $50 voucher so I can,
they'll get a chicken sandwich
with mushrooms. Oh Shit.
Was that good? God dammit.
I had a good chicken sandwich in there.
It all worked out. So anyways, this,
this is, this is what happened
this week. So anyways,
so I've been driving around
this, uh, my, uh, my hybrid,
there was dented,
it got dented initially
cause some douchebag backed
into me and I got that fixed
immediately. And then the next time it
got dented it was because my girlfriend,
uh, I dunno, she misspoke
in a parking way,
put it that way and she fucking,
I dunno what she did,
but it came home and it looked like
fucking big foot had a pair of timberlands
on and stomp the Goddamn quarter panel.
So I've been driving around with that.
Right. Was scrape marks on the
side. It just, it just, you know,
as a man,
you don't want to have a car with a
den that it just makes you feel like a
fucking loser.
Forget about the fact that it's a hybrid
and it has those little fucking search
roll up size tires.
Okay.
So I finally get the thing
fixed after four months,
you know, cause I want to make sure she
learned how to parallel park, you know,
full. She fucked the thing up
again. So that's taken care of.
So I get the Goddamn thing fixed.
This is how excited I am.
I have, my girl comes to pick me up at
the airport as I'm hugging her, right?
Like World War II ended.
I'm looking over her shoulder looking
to see that there's no dent in the car.
And you know what I mean?
It's almost like I was cheating on
her in like an automotive kind of wet.
So I was excited. The fucking thing
look great. Everything was fantastic.
And I drove this car that was on Monday.
Thursday I go over my management's office.
I valet the fucking thing, one
of those deals where, you know,
I valet it but I park it cause there's
a spot right there. I go to my lunch,
I come back from lunch and there's
a fucking dent, my car again,
the exact same spot, the exact
same sites and now it's the bumper.
And I,
I swear to God,
I never understood the
expression I was beside myself.
I never knew what the fuck that meant.
But when in that moment I get it,
it's some sort of out of body
experience where I was just,
I had to look at my driver's license,
my license plate,
like seven times. I was
like, there's no fucking way.
That's my car is his camping my car.
And I just kept looking down and it was,
it was my fucking pot.
So then I look over at the valets,
okay mind you listen to the exact same
spot and they're not looking at me.
This is all shit I put together
afterwards. But I was so flustered.
I came up there,
I fucking voice went up like
nine office. Oh, he's even mad.
I was literally like a,
I felt like it was going to fake
it. Don't see those old movies when
they got some broad and you know,
they get their,
those dresses down to the floor that has
like 52 layers of underwear underneath
him.
That's why I should have had all my loads,
a fucking hoop skirt and I
should have just fainted.
Would one of those little umbrellas that
you spin around and it doesn't really
keep the rain or the sun off yet.
It's just supposed to make
you look more attractive.
I should have been holding one of
those and I, that's what I should've,
that's how flustered I was.
So the fucking parking attendants
are like, I'm like, well,
you know what happened to my car? And
they were just like, uh, yeah, they, uh,
somebody, uh, somebody hit
hit it, somebody, he, I might,
who hit it, I don't know. And a day
we backed it over there and, uh,
somebody here did back in the day,
that day, you know, everything,
the fucking word sounded like it
started with a d, You know, so,
um,
like I can't fucking believe in and then
they give me the sheet of paper to fill
out,
you know,
they should have told me that they fucking
did it because someone else hit me.
First of all,
you saw the fucking dentist con,
there's no way these guys didn't hear it,
you know,
and they just automatically give
me this form saying that they,
I guess they're going to pay for it.
So I'm filling the shit out.
And it wasn't until I drove away
that I started thinking about it,
I pulled over and I'm looking at the
dent and it's the exact same shape as the
polls in the garage.
So obviously one of those fuckers
drove it into a pole and then
after they drove it into a pole,
they stuck it back in the space where I,
where I had left it
and then tried to fucking, then they would
look and down, not make an eye contact.
I think they were trying to
hope that I didn't see it.
I hope one of those fucking guys is one
of my listeners every week. All right,
dude, why don't you just
fucking constantly and let
me know you did it. Okay.
I know. Like you don't want to get
fired, right? Is that what it is?
I just can't fucking
believe it, man. I just,
I it just so goddamn depressing my
fucking car. It's got another God. Damn.
I just got to fix four days.
I drove around for four days.
I don't understand it.
You know what I mean?
It's not like when my car
didn't have a dent in it.
I started driving around and making fun
of people who had dents in their cars.
So there was some sort of
fucking calmer going on.
Why didn't deserve to not
have a dentist fucking car. So
that's it. Now it's unreal,
man. I can't have a car.
It doesn't have a fucking Bennett.
And uh,
I really wish I didn't tell this story
because I started off in a great mood.
And as you can tell by my tone,
I'm not in such a great mood anymore.
It's just really fucking freshman.
I'd say what's extra frustrating?
They gave me this piece of paper with
some lady's name on it and they're like,
yeah, she doesn't call you in the
next five days. Give me a call.
And like I said, I was so
beside myself. I said, okay.
And it wasn't until day three.
I was like, wait a minute.
He doesn't call me in the next five days.
How about in the next five
fucking minutes? Fucking
idiot. You're ruined my car.
Or this phantom lady ruined it.
And then you got in it in it for some
fucking reason to put it back in the same
spot. You five foot, two
inch fucking jackass.
I just, Oh, maybe that's why I put it.
Dennis came to see over the
fucking steering wheel. All right.
You know what,
I listened back to last week's podcast
and I just really felt like I sounded
like I was too God damn upset
on it and it was too depressing.
So I tried to start this one off and try
to stay focused in a good mood and then
look what happened.
What am I had 13 minutes
in and I'm already flipping
out again. I just, you know,
anybody else? Anybody else got any
fucking stories out there like that,
that can make me feel better?
Maybe I could read to some
of the listeners. I mean,
I want to hear some of your,
I fixed my car or I just bought a brand
new car and then some fucking cunt.
Jesus. No, no, no. I'll drop it.
The C word. All right. Let's look,
let's get back to my dates here.
Okay. Um, so that's the deal.
I haven't ended hybrid again. You know,
let's think of some positive shit.
The Celtics won one game,
like they had to out in la,
one of the greatest comebacks ever.
And, uh, they get to more in Boston.
Let's hope they're going to win it.
I actually went to game three,
Celtics lost that one, but
it was still awesome to go
to the, uh, go to the finals.
But I got to admit, man, they'll go,
referees were, uh, they were little,
they were crazy.
The amount of files that was the game
right after Phil Jackson was complaining.
Remember that game too when they called
56 files on the liquors and like three
on the Celtics. So he bitched about it
and I think the referees get pissed,
but kind of knew he was right. So they
were like calling a ton on the Celtics,
but they also kind of going, fuck you
Phil Jackson, we're still running shifts.
So they still called a bunch on the
Lakers and I don't think the ball went up
and down the court three times
without them blowing the whistle.
Like there was never any sort of like
slow to the game and it kind of sucked as
a fan because they kept cock
blocking the excitement.
Even when the Lakers were going on a run,
you know,
even as a self expanse sitting
there, it was pretty, you know,
it was cool to see them going bananas
and feeling like I was at a finals.
But every time they'd start to go nuts,
they pull some ticky tack file.
And then the other way when they would
start getting quiet and I just touched
standing up talking shit, they, they,
they call another bullshit once. So
I don't know what the fuck they're
doing it. But in the last night's game,
I thought the officiating was really
weird. It was like the beginning the game,
like, all right, they're
going gonna let them play.
They will lighten the Mug each other,
and then all of a sudden
they stayed start calling.
They just ticky tack that it's not
consistent. Does that mean consistent?
Plus we lost, so I'm probably a
little cunty too. Um, but anyways, uh,
here we go.
The punchline in Atlanta this week from
June 19th to the 21st this is one of my
favorite gigs and I absolutely
loved going to that club.
It's just an old school club. If you live
anywhere near there, please come down.
I've got a brand new hour and I also have
a solution to the uh, the gas problem.
I really do something
that would be effective,
a very effective if did I say ineffective,
very effective within eat
and that wasn't a aspect.
Did like it. Uh, you know at,
that's one of those things I never know
the difference, the effect or effect.
It might have to look that up.
Um, all right. And then, uh,
July I'm going to be at the
Improv and Pittsburgh from uh,
July 10th through the 13th. Then, uh,
the next Gig I have after that
is July 31st through August.
The fuck is it? Hang on, hang on the page.
There's somebody at the comedy works.
That's what it is. Economy works
in Denver, Colorado from August,
I mean July 31st or is it 30th in to turn
the page the last fucking day in July
through a Saturday. August
2nd. Nice. No Sunday.
Got To love that. Yeah.
It's 31 days in July.
31 days have November except
for September and Friday.
Honestly, that one go. All right.
Um, do I have anything else to hype?
I think that's pretty much
it. Uh, podcast questions.
All of a sudden nobody's asked me podcast
questions about what happened last two
weeks. I didn't answer any questions to
now you guys, you can't ask me anything.
I got a question for you. Where the fuck
are all the questions? How you over it?
Um, I don't know why. Okay. I think
it's time to wrap this fucking thing up.
What the hell was I just looking up?
Oh,
effect an effect.
I'm trying to teach you guys something
effect and effect you like how I don't
know the difference and I'm going
to act like I'm teaching you.
Which of these sentences are correct.
Rising oil prices will have
an effect on nearly everyone.
That's correct. With
an [inaudible], right?
Why don't you just give me the fucking
definition I hit when they do this?
Her emotional outbursts
first was purely for effect.
You know, wait a minute. All
of these sentences correctly,
employee effect and effect.
In most situations we use effect
is a noun and an effect is a verb.
Well, what the fuck did they mean? How
about giving me a definition first?
You know what? This is like. This is
like how they, I was taught Algebra,
you know what I mean?
Like everything would math up
until eighth grade for me anyways,
was numbers.
If you fucking Asian,
I'm sure you were doing
calculus in the third grade,
but let's just stick with your random
fucking stupid American hair. All right?
Right up to eighth grade,
it was all fucking numbers.
Then all of a sudden ninth grade comes
around and they throw the fucking
alphabet in there and there was no soda
before they go in, you know, little,
little speech like, Hey, this is
going to be a little different.
The do just started doing it. He
just started throwing, you know,
foil first outside,
inside last, uh, you know,
dial it all that high school man,
opposite angles are congruent and
none of his shit may and you just,
you just repeated it like you were
in a cult. They just stand up.
They opposite angles are congruent.
Opposite angles are congruent.
Did nobody had any idea what the fuck
they went to and they just had a triangle
on the board?
That's what this website is like.
Get it right online.com.
Uh,
there's no fucking definition
how these fly correctly. Webster's
curse this birthday. Fucking thanks.
All right. Hey, is this exciting?
Is this an exciting podcast as I attempt
to fucking look up Goddamn word and
fail miserably.
Effect effect.
Cause you didn't do this shit at work
and that's the mission, you know,
and you try to look up like Robbie
Knievel and try to guess what year he was
born. All right, here we go.
Perfect definition of effect
to have an influence or
effect or a change in,
you know what? Fuck this word.
Okay. You know what I mean?
That's like the difference
between a truck and a car.
And in the definition of
car, they describe it as a
fucking truck. You know what?
Sometimes you got to cut your losses
and you got to realize that you're not
going to know some things in
life. So that's just one of
them, you know? All right.
What does this podcast, this has just
been spam for the last three minutes.
I apologize. Um, you know
what? I just had to eat.
You know what?
I should actually turn this into a
contest and say I'm going to give out,
give you a free 100 DVDs. If you
could guess what the fuck I just ate,
cause you'll never guess what
it was thicker than most. Okay?
I'm going to give you hints and
you can all play along at home.
All right? This is
something, it's a dessert.
It's uh,
something that they used to have creepy
commercials about with a high pitched
voice and you put it in the freezer.
Three answer into one.
I actually just has slice of cookie puss.
There's no way to say that
without fucking laugh.
And I just had a piece of cookie ice
cream cake, whatever the fuck you call it,
it's ice cream and cake. Just like
affect an effect. Did the same thing.
It's fucking incestuous. And
you, I got to tell you something.
If you've never had it,
it's just as disgusting as it sounds.
You know what I mean?
Some things are just named perfectly
and cookie posts. It just what it is.
It's a stank ranked slutty
ass fucking disgusting cake.
Like if, if, uh, who's
the right horde of pickup?
Just going to say a Paris Hilton
was a cake. She wouldn't be,
she'd be like a fucking blow pop.
Sorry. Uh, I don't fucking know.
All right. Whatever. My sugar
levels up through the fucking roof.
Why do I have up God damn
fucking ice cream cake?
Because I turned 40 last Tuesday
gym on Sunday. That's the way I was
dying. I rejoined, I'm like, fuck this.
It turned 40 on Tuesday. Let
me, let me bang out 500 sit ups.
The last 500 sit ups would
be in 39 years old. Um,
yeah. Yeah. It's pretty fucking brutal.
But I'll tell you something and
somebody shows up, you know,
you have a party place and somebody
shows up with a cookie, puss,
ice cream and you know, it's not that bad.
Not because you eat it, it tastes good.
You're more thinking like, well, you know,
maybe I was addicted to sweets I need
and his fucking horse shit every day.
All right. Did we learn
anything this week? Yes we did.
We're going to learn that bill burr.
It's going to be on the fucking the, uh,
that's like guys choice
awards this Sunday. And uh,
somewhere between eight and
4:00 AM on Spike TV and a,
I am the VP at the punch
line in Atlanta and uh,
I don't know the definition of
effect and aspect and a cookie puss.
Ice Cream tastes like
it tastes like Eskimo.
Uh, yeah. You went down on
a fucking Eskimo cooker.
It's really fucking, it's,
it's just, it's fucking awful.
Let me see if I can just,
first of all, some Carvel.
It's got a big green fucking
ice cream nose with a Conan.
And I just can't imagine like
you ever see those people?
They're so fat that
like fucking bedridden.
This is the kind of shit that
they eat because you know,
everybody's out of shape.
I'm fucking out of shape right now.
You know what I mean? Everybody, once
you get past 30, you got a fucking gun.
Nobody looks good without their shirt on.
It's everybody stopped winding on
that fucking biggest loser. Okay?
No one looks good to quit
your crying. Okay. But uh,
those people who gets so big that
they're just fucking bed written,
you really have to go out of your way.
You have to go above and
beyond to get that big,
you know what I mean?
Slow metabolism.
Fuck you and your fucking metabolism.
No you don't.
You are eating cookie puss nightly,
nightly basis.
I had just had a snack. What
did you have? I had cookie puss.
All fucking 3000 fucking calories a slice.
Here we go. And that's how I like
to fucking ended. I liked to,
to attack the band written and that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast APP.
Please, uh, re up with the questions.
I swear to God, I'll read them.
I will answer them next week, and somebody
please give me a fucking definition,
the difference between effect and effect,
because, you know, I said, you know,
I looked it up and they use the definition
of the other word in the fucking
definition, which is annoying.
All right. Um, that is it. Uh,
thanks to everybody came up to me to
see my show in Raleigh, North Carolina.
It's the most disjointed fucking podcast
ever. Um, did I use that word correctly?
Um, in Raleigh, north Caroline's, um,
I'm adding a bunch of new dates coming up.
I got a date coming up with
the stress factor in New
Jersey. Uh, I got to college.
Umass Amhurst going to be
adding that date shortly.
Uh, what else? What else? I
don't know. Sometime in August,
beginning of September. So look for
those dates and, uh, anything else,
just go to billboard.com and,
um, and that's it. All right.
You have to weaker.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].